what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Wolverine and Ghost Rider
weapons of Vengeance now for those of
you guys who were just catching up with
us the long and short of this is that
Wolverine's possessed by a demon called
bager ghoul and we don't really know a
whole lot about this guy but he's
basically set upon the path of finding
whatever mutants he can find across the
world and really the United States if
we're being honest with ourselves and
kill them where he can now there is a
whole motivation behind that we'll talk
a little bit more about that as we get
through this story but this initially
picks up at Cedar City Utah which is
almost in the immediate vicinity of
project Hellfire and again we'll discuss
the nature of project Hellfire because
it's really cool but like him going on
this war path is really more the result
of these mutants who are basically
blowing up this house because the house
was taken from them now that's one of
the things that I do want to make you
guys aware of this is why I say what's
going on with fall of X right now is
very similar to what we saw with Chris
claremont's X-Men run with Uncanny X-Men
and like project wide awake and all that
kind of stuff because much in the same
way that you saw the mutant population
fighting back for their own rights
really and like the old Chris Claremont
X-Men stories you're seeing that here
and what's going on is there are a
couple of mutants that are just riding
around from neighborhood to Neighborhood
blowing up people's entire homes they're
kind of taking like hot shots at
Humanity gorilla Warfare tactics if you
want to call it that right the human
race took our homes they took away our
right to exist we're going to take their
homes and their lives right we're just
going to blow the whole place up with
them in it and so this ultimately brings
the attention of hellverine now
depending on your perspective this is a
terrible decision for these guys to be
doing because the best thing the mutant
population could be doing right now is
laying low marshalling their forces and
biting their time because if Humanity
truly believes that they are dead and
gone it's only a matter of time before
they begin to lower their guard and when
that happens you strike right like when
they're at their weakest point when they
believe that everything is safe that's
when you strike because you catch them
completely and totally unaware now for
hellverine himself showing up here and
attacking these guys he kills them on
the spot and then he basically starts
restructuring their bodies into this
really grotesque form of art only to
discover that there's actually a baby in
the car and this is when he's given
instruction by father Pike which is take
it out right like eliminate it and
that's where you start to see this kind
of inner turmoil with Wolverine now for
his part Johnny Blaze the Ghost Rider
tries to step in but like we covered in
the last video both he and Wolverine had
already been captured and Johnny Blaze
has this kind of mind control helmet put
over his head that prevents the Ghost
Rider from manifesting more so than that
this is how the demon was bonded to
Wolverine just because of the fact that
with Wolverine under their control they
can seemingly do anything they want with
him which includes bonding a demon to
him and sending sending him out as a
kind of force of nature into the world
and so following that you pick up with
Talia warro and Jeff Bannister now like
we've talked about before Talia isn't
really like the sidekick of Johnny Blaze
she's more of like a person that deals
with the occult that's kind of helping
him on his journey and then Jeff
banister is the contact for Wolverine in
the CIA the two of them are literally
hot on the trail trying to find both
Johnny Blaze and Wolverine but this is
when we get some really cool backstory
about the nature of B ghoul and a lot of
you guys called this in the last video
kudos to you for getting it right I
wasn't 100% sure of whether or not it
was true but as it turns out Bou was
created by the demon Mesto now the
reason why I say I wasn't 100% sure it
was true is because there were demons
that existed in Marvel Comics before
Mesto there are those who came into
existence around the same time as him
and some who came into existence after
so it's not as though Mesto is quite
literally the Marvel Comics equivalent
of of Lucifer Morning Star from judeo
Christianity right the first of the
Fallen that kind of thing the original
demon he's basically just a helll Lord
and there's a whole bunch of those that
run around Marvel Comics he's just the
most popular one but this guy created
boul literally just out of sheer boredom
we're told that right like he was bored
by the mundane nature of the suffering
all around him this devil as we all know
has style you can find him in the finest
silks the most decadent desserts
ostentatious architecture luscious
guitar licks and Sumptuous curves of
Flesh sin can be a beautiful thing now
what they're talking about here in
relation to this and this is kind of a
Sidetrack on the nature of Mesto
longtime readers of Marvel already know
this so this is really more for the new
reader misto is this guy that will
approach you in any point when you seem
to be your most vulnerable or when it's
the best possible opportunity for him to
strike a bargain with you it doesn't
necessarily have to be something where
like your life is coming to an end or
you lost everything and you'll do
anything to somehow get it all back it's
not always like that right it's maybe
just some kind of guy out there who
isn't an orchestra and he wants to be
the best violinist and so Mesto will
come to him and he will make a deal and
what misto does is he'll give you the
bargain that you're asking for just not
in the way that you think because sure
right you'll become the best violinist
in existence but like your fingers will
be numb right or like you'll lose your
hands in a car wreck or something along
those lines so you have all the skill to
be the best violinist that was ever in
existence you just won't be able to do
it and then when you die he'll get your
soul right he'll collect your soul so he
kind of appears in everything right he's
always out there lurking waiting for a
chance to manipulate people and so
that's why we're told bogra grul was
created to make art out of punishment
art out of death that is its compulsion
to kill beautifully and erect bloody
monuments in celebration of Mesto so
that's why it does the things that it
does now in terms of why it's going
after the mutant population that's where
Jeff banister really begins to
understand what's going on here that the
nature of really B ghoul and the
character of Bram who was introduced to
us in this story as B ghoul's first
human host came in the form of the fact
that bram's parents worship the dark and
they of course produced Bram in a
cemetery on top of a grave of a guy who
had been convicted and hanged for murder
and so it's like the most sinful act
that a person could possibly engage in
this basically allowed The Offspring
right Bram to become a vessel for bogra
goul who was just waiting for his time
to take over the boy once they get to
project Hellfire it all starts to click
for Jeff and he starts to realize this
is just a government program that what
the government is looking to do once
they became aware of Bram is basically
harness demonic energy now that's not
uncommon for the government to do and
that's the nature of the side projects
right weapons plus and then all the
weapons that came under it Weapons 1 two
three all the way up to weapon 10 and
Beyond right weapon 10 being Wolverine
the whole thing behind this is that the
federal government is always looking for
a way to create some kind of super
soldier sometimes that super soldier
comes in the form of a Captain America
type person right a serum that they're
injected with they're exposed to
radiation they come out and they can
just run really fast and punch really
hard other times it's bonding adamantium
to people's skeletons but any method
that they can use to develop some kind
of a super soldier that can be used in
nextg Warfare they will take they always
contract out and doing so and so
seemingly the federal government is well
aware of what it is that father Pike is
doing but the ends justify the means
because if what they can do is take a
demonic entity and then Bond it to a
living h or an entire platoon of
soldiers they would basically dominate
the entirety of Modern Warfare right
nobody would be able to overcome them so
it is very very shady but it's just the
nature of government programs in Marvel
Comics and so Wolverine who's still kind
of wrestling with this demonic Side and
being ordered to take this kid out he
ultimately rejects it right like he says
no that's not going to happen and he
stabs himself in order to kind of try to
bring himself back to a degree because
remember the way in which wolver bra is
able to regain his senses at least as
best he can is by inflicting pain on
himself and so where he's told by father
Pike you serve Mesto you serve the
United States government and you serve
me ultimately Wolverine seems to be able
to overcome this if just only by a small
measure and so this leads to Father Pike
basically teleporting out and then in
turn traveling directly to Wolverine
himself now once he's gone and out of
the picture that's when Talia and Jeff B
anister show up here and then free
Johnny Blaze from his control and this
goes exactly the way that you would
expect and it's amazing because where
helverin is back on the prow with
control being retaken by B ghoul and
father Pike he heads towards this town
that has 97 mutants in it and understand
he will lay waste to the entire place
there will be no Discerning between
innocent and guilty in his eyes everyone
will die if that's what ends up
happening and so what is it going on is
that because this is all done by way of
the Mind Control helmet Jeff banister
destroys the helmet which basically
takes away any mind control that father
Pike has over Wolverine albeit he's
still possessed by the demon entity and
then Talia warad removes the helmet from
Johnny Blaze and says free the Ghost
Rider right like this is the only thing
that's going to be able to stop VRA goul
nothing else is going to be able to end
this guy because remember the nature of
the Ghost Rider is that it was also
created by Mesto but it was created by
Mesto to have just unrivaled levels of
power it's one of the reasons why Ghost
Rider is so astronomically capable he
can go against the Hulk he can stand
against galatis I mean it's crazy how
much power this guy has so Ghost Rider
immediately manifests and then takes off
after wolver rain the kicker about all
this is that with Bram being the
original host and B ghoul being taken
away from Bram Bram doesn't want to lose
it anymore and in fact he wants back and
father Pike actually kind of agrees to
allow it to happen because what father
Pike starts to realize is that where
Wolverine is kind of like the perfect
killing machine and under an ideal
circumstance he's the best person to be
bonded to this Wolverine has his own
moral compass and whether it's through
telepathic conditioning from his time
with the X-Men Gan gray Professor Xavier
perhaps even Emma Frost to a degree or
just his experience in dealing with
these kinds of things he's not allowing
himself to fully Bond right like they
can control him but they can't fully
dominate him if that makes any sense but
Bram on the other hand is a willing host
and he'll do whatever it is they tell
him to do and the reason for this is
that ever since bagl was taken away from
him he is just having an incredibly
difficult time coping he's having an
incredibly difficult time feeling whole
he wants the demon back and so once he
reaches out and tries to collect it unto
himself Ghost Rider shows up crashes
into Wolverine and it's just like so uh
we've been hunting this demon for so
many years tonight we're sending him
back to hell and it's like the coolest
thing ever because now it's literally
just straight up Ghost Rider fighting
against this ridiculously powerful
demonic force and B roul knows exactly
who Ghost Rider is right it's not as
though he had no idea or no knowledge
about Ghost Rider or anything he doesn't
really Express a whole lot of fear here
like oh my God it's Ghost Rider what am
I going to do it's not really anything
like that but it's like you failed Mesto
your job was to be a force of Reckoning
on Earth for Mesto and you turned
against him and you basically became a
force that sends his forces back to hell
and so he's like I will make a monument
of your bones for every demon in hell to
piss on and the response of Ghost Rider
is you cannot punish me because I exist
in a state of constant punishment and I
am no one's servant right and so he says
wake up wolverin just because you carry
chains does not mean you are a slave to
Mesto which is true because Johnny Blaze
was supposed to be a slave to misto he
escaped that fate and then he became a
guy who traveled around the world and
sent Demons back to hell and so while
father Pike is watching all of this he's
just kind of astonished by it all
because wolver rain as the helain
possessed by boul actually starts to
overcome Ghost Rider and doesn't really
kill him but he seemingly overpowers him
and so father Pike says like come with
us right but the response of Wolverine
is no like I'm done with all of this and
so father Pike pulls bogra ghoul
directly out of wolver rain and starts
to reinsert The Entity back into brand
and the funny thing here is that
Wolverine is kind of able to pull it
back unto himself right and just say no
like that's not going to happen so what
this does is it really introduces the
idea that despite all the power that
bagul has as a demonic entity he's still
beholden to the will of whatever host
he's bonded to which is a great caveat
here it's a great way to explain why it
doesn't just jump from one host to the
next wreaking havoc around the entirety
of the world I do love that right and in
fact that's been an on-running theme in
the Ghost Rider comics for quite some
time and so what ends up happening is
that using this one last bit of power
that he has at his disposal hellverine
stabs father Pike right kills him on the
spot using his claws and then in turn
throws him into the fire pits that are
going to send him to hell because what
had happened is he had opened a kind of
portal of sorts beseeching Mesto asking
for M festo's Aid in harnessing and
controlling the power of boul well now
father Pik gets exactly what he's
looking for right like you called down
the Thunder my friend and now you got it
you wanted to see misto go see him right
spend the rest of Eternity burning in
Hell misto is going to be happy to have
you there right he doesn't care who's in
hell as long as he has the most number
of people in his section of Hell
following that Bram jumps on to wolver
rain and then immediately starts
absorbing the entirety of B ghoul into
himself and that's when Ghost Rider
makes this amazing monologue right he
says the spirit is a curse but it's a
curse I have to live with we're entwined
at this point one and the same I know
the writer feels the same as me so as
powerful as Wolverine might be Bram is
home for B goul they've killed together
now they'll die together caught in the
punishing light of my damnation stair
now the damnation stair of Johnny Blaze
is a relatively new ability that was
introduced in 2019 but we haven't really
seen it used all that often so this is
one of the first times that we actually
get to see it in full display and it's
amazing so there's two things to know
about the damnation stair one is that it
is unique to Johnny Blaze seemingly no
other Ghost Riders have it and just
largely seems to come out of the point
in Marvel Comics when Johnny Blaze
became the king of Hell the other thing
here is the difference between the
damnation stare and the pen and stare so
the pen and stare only works on people
that have two eyes and it forces them to
endure all the pain and suffering that
they've caused but it doesn't work on
people like Thanos or The Punisher
because with Thanos for example he loved
it he enjoyed it because he loves
causing death and suffering everywhere
he goes and The Punisher genuinely
believed that what he was doing was
right so it never really impacted him on
that level but for everybody else
they'll just experience horrible
horrible pain and usually end up in a
catatonic State what the damnation stare
does is it judges whether or not that
person is allowed to remain on Earth or
to be sent to hell and in this instance
because of everything that Bram and
bogra ghoul had done they're effectively
locked away and presumably sent to hell
we don't know specific how the power
works and in fact the ending of this
will give us a much better understanding
of how this ability functions but once
this stair is done Johnny Blaze reverts
back to his human form and then of
course the entirety of the weapons plus
project Hellfire lab is effectively
destroyed right the whole place is just
burned up and blown up and the whole
thing goes away but while you have
Wolverine and Ghost Rider that go about
their own business you have Bram who's
still locked away as this kind of stone
statue out there in the middle of
nowhere but where a bird lands on this
statue itself Bram is seemingly still
there in cased in stone with his eyes
glowing red so what it looks like is
it's designed to just kind of lock a
person away but if they are of
sufficient power they are able to escape
again this power hasn't really been used
all that often so we don't know the ins
and outs of how it works but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end if you need to get caught
up on weapons of Vengeance make sure you
click this link to playlist and I will
catch you all later peace